apparently some civilians got their
hands on Arkham Knight we rounded them
up brought them in for questioning
have a seat so you're one of the first
to play batman arkham knight yeah i
played it yeah i played the game yeah
I've played it what do you want to know
what do you want to know I didn't do it
unless do it is the beating of a bunch
of thugs and yeah they're kicking some
ass
haha Batman's out there and he is
looking it isn't ben affleck shape okay
okay yeah boy and this time he wrote a
car and it's got serious firepower i
have a canon the odds are against them
but numbers don't matter look at how
many people I've just beat up yeah how'd
you do how'd I do Oh baby I got some
moves Oh God oh uh oh look out oh I just
thought from the car it's big like size
of a city big here we go let's take off
sweet I say I'm a natural what what what
what Oh Wiz was here dude did he mention
me no game is fine made a really good
time this looks great kept my cool
stayed focused fly kick is pretty much
the coolest thing to do smoke pellet is
always fun I play tough
good night everybody didn't Minkus any
know some bones needed to get broken I
broke those bones oh oh yeah yeah haha
games intensity whoa voices are really
good Harvey might feel bad about this
Batman especially that two-faced see all
of Batman's gadgets they're controlled
by my fingertips and they're not
voice-activated grappling hook that
doesn't seem to be a bullet no rifle on
crashed into stuff right here check
that's where I hit that little mind
thing that electrocuted my car started a
small fire that got through that check
you can Batman can't do it alone you
know one your fame Oh slo-mo oh my
Nightwing now I think the rogues gallery
has been very busy particularly the
Riddler he's really he's set up a
racetrack Batmobile can drive up walls
dude Oh up the wall what do you call
this is that vertical horizontal
something I'm wall-climbing baby I'm
also testing a theory that it might be
able to go into water don't go down in
the water it's not a boatmobile it's
chaos out there
I grabbed a bat from a dude and then I
used his bet against us it's what we've
been waiting for be the Batman be the
Batman be the Batman oh I was the bed
the best penet I am